you're right my public Explorations are
not driven by audience service
but by my lack of ability for
discovering understanding or following
the relevant authorities so I have to
develop my own thoughts since I think
autonomously these thoughts cannot
always be very good that's you
apologizing for the chaos of your
thoughts or perhaps not apologizing just
identify it but let me ask the question
uh since we talked about
Michael Levin and yourself who I think
are very kind of uh radical big
independent thinkers uh can we reverse
engineer your process of thinking
autonomously
how do you do it how can humans do it
how can you avoid being influenced
by uh what is the stage
stage three
well why would you want to do that it's
uh you see what is working for you and
if it's uh not working for you you build
another structure that works better for
you right and so I've found myself in
when I was thrown into this world in a
state where my intuitions were not
working for me I was not able to
um understand how I would be able to
survive in this world and build the
things that I was interested in build
the kinds of relationship I needed to
but work on the topics that I wanted to
make progress on and so I had to learn
and I for me Twitter is not some tool of
publication it's not something where I
put stuff that I entirely believe to be
true and provable it's an interactive
notebook in which I explore
possibilities
and I found that when I try to
understand how the mind and how
Consciousness works I was quite
optimistic I thought I need to need to
be a big body of knowledge that I can
just study and that works and so I
entered studies in philosophy and
computer science and later psychology
and a bit of Neuroscience and so on and
I was disappointed by what I found
because I found that the questions of
how Consciousness and so on Works how
emotion Works how it's possible that the
system can experience anything how
motivation emerges in the mind when not
being answered by the authorities that I
met and the schools that were around
and instead I found that with individual
thinkers that had useful ideas that
sometimes were good sometimes were not
so good sometimes were adopted by a
large group of people sometimes were
rejected by large groups of people but
for me it was much more interesting to
see these Minds as individuals and in my
perspective thinking is still something
that is done not in groups that has to
be done by individuals so that motivated
you to become an individual thinker
yourself I didn't have a choice okay I
didn't find the group that thought in a
way where I felt okay
um I can't just adopt everything that
everybody thinks here and now I
understand how Consciousness works right
so or how the mind works or how thinking
works or what thinking even is or What
feelings are and how they're implemented
and so on so to figure all this out I
had to take a lot of ideas from
individuals and then try to put them
together in something that works for
myself and on one hand I think it helps
if you try to go down and find first
principles on on which you can recreate
how thinking Works how languages work
what representation is when the
representation is necessary
how the relationship between
representing agent and the world Works
in general
but how do you escape the influence once
again the pressure of the crowd
whether it's
you in responding to the the pressure or
you being swept up by the pressure if
you even just look at Twitter the
opinions of the crowd I don't feel
pressure from the crowd I'm completely
immune to that in the same sense I don't
have respect for authority I have
respect for what an individual is
accomplishing or have a respect for
mental Firepower or so but it's not that
I meet somebody and gets electrod and
unable to speak
um or when a large group of people has a
certain idea that is different from mine
I don't necessarily feel intimidated
which has often been a problem for me in
my life because I like instincts that
other people develop at a very young age
and that helped with their
self-preservation in a social
environment
so I had to learn a lot of things the
hard way
yeah
so is there a practical advice you can
give on how to think parenting
paradigmatically how to think
independently or you know because you've
kind of said I had no choice
but I think
to a degree you have a choice
because you said you want to be
productive and I think thinking
independent is productive if what you're
curious about is understanding the world
especially when the problems are very
kind of new and open
so
it seems like
this is a active process like we can
choose to do that we can practice it
well there's a very basic question when
you read a theory that you find
convincing or interesting how do you
know
it is very interesting to figure out
what are the sources of that other
person not uh which authority can they
refer to that is then taking off the
burden of being truthful but how did
this Authority in turn know what is the
epistemic chain to observables what are
the first principles from which the
whole thing is derived and
when I was young I was not blessed with
a lot of
um
people around myself who knew how to
make proofs from first principles and I
think mathematicians do this quite
naturally but most of the great
mathematicians do not become
mathematicians in school but they tend
to be self-taught
because school teachers tend not to be
mathematicians right they tend not to be
people who derive things from first
principles so when you ask your school
teacher why does two plus two equal four
um that's your school teacher give you
the right answer like um it's a simple
game and many simple games that we could
play and
um most of those games that you could
just take different roles would not lead
to an interesting arithmetic and so it's
just an exploration but you can try what
happens if you take different axioms and
here is how you build axioms and derive
um addition from them and build Edition
is some basically syntactic sugar in it
and
so this I wish that somebody would have
opened me this Vista and explained to me
how I can build a language in my own
mind and from which I can derive what
I'm seeing and how I can which I can
make geometry and Counting and
um
all the number games that we are playing
in our life and on the other hand I felt
that I learned a lot of this while I was
programming as a child when you start
out with a computer like a Commodore 64
who doesn't which doesn't have a lot of
functionality it's relatively easy to
see how a bunch of relatively simple
circuits are just mostly performing
hashes between bit patterns and how you
can build the entirety of mathematics
and computation on top of this and all
the representational languages that you
need
man Commodore 64 could be one of the
sexiest machines ever built if I saw say
so myself